obviously you are
legitimately at the very top
uh in terms of performance
accomplishment in in the field so what
have you learned about
what it takes to train
to become not just elite but the best
well i i um
a lot of people when you say train they
see training hard
i believe you need to be very constant
and very disciplined you need to train
but you don't need to train hard every
day that's what john taught me
um
for me is the nervous system sometimes i
feel if i
load it up too much it comes to a point
that you're
it's too much there there is no no more
information that i can absorb
so
uh
and i do believe that it's something
that you can train to your the capacity
your capacity of being able to learn of
absorbing certain thing
and uh i did a lot of volume of training
but when i when i was getting ready for
a fight especially during sparring day
i like to do it quick because my when i
fight it's five round of five minute
i don't like to to spend
um
[Music]
an hour or two hours in a gym because
i need to know how hard i can be
going for 25 minutes you know not for
two hours for 25 minutes and my last
fight
john and i we we
we
we were thinking of how could we
make me more
uh
of a better finisher you know more
opportunists
and then john i remember we we when we
were training with gordon jake shill
came gary tony
my round of grappling were different
than if i would be training for uh
abu dhabi you know for for ebi or like
some like in grappling the round or
longer but
in a mixed martial art fight
it's very rare that you're gonna spend
more than four minutes or
four minutes and a half on the ground
it's it's very unlikely i mean it
couldn't can happen but
so
i
do you remember we did around three
minutes we did all the round i was doing
were three minute round so it gives a
different
rhythm to the training it forced me to
be more opportunist
to be more of a finisher because i had
only three minutes to to do what i
needed to do
so if i if i see something i need to to
go for the kill right away i cannot be
too over patient you know what i mean
and it it served me well in my last
fight and i think it that's a good
blueprint to follow
um when you're a mixed martial art
fighter i if i would if
the result was great and i think
maybe i should have done that before it
was a great great idea that we had not
to do uh be very careful and doing too
much volume
yeah just try to get out and then try to
focus on finishing and getting getting
out of it i mean
to build up your foundation i believe
you need a lot of volume but yeah when
you get ready for competition you need
some to be something that replicate
what you're going to be facing
what are we talking about what do you
think
like is there rest days five days a week
twice a day once a day is there any one
formula like that or no this this i
don't i do not believe in overtraining i
believe in under arrest
i believe
you can be under arrest and
people
always link that immediately to the
volume of their how much volume they
they train
which it could be something else
how are you feeling um emotionally are
you are you having uh
problems uh personal problem do you ever
have a hard time sleeping because you
have a like someone died or yeah i don't
know like
you hold money you're broke or what like
you know what i mean it could be
anything
uh
there's something that can affect you
psychologically or emotionally
that made it in a way that you cannot
sleep well because your your stress your
cortisol level is high or
you're you know what i mean all these
factors need to be take taken in
consideration it's not only about the
volume of training people
always think
the volume of tr the training is not the
only thing
that can affect recuperation which is
not
you know yeah he said to minimize the
amount of stress from all kinds of
factors it's a very stressful job to be
a professional
combat athlete whether you're a grappler
a boxer a kickboxer a fighter and you
need to be taken
as a
into account
is it more or less stressful than
marriage just kidding
uh next question uh
um
so
i don't know how to ask this question
given what george just said but you're
training three times a day
and finishing and what what have you
learned about what what brings out the
best in you
as as the elite level grabber um so over
the recent years i've actually changed
it up a little bit
when i was
coming up through
from white to black belt
i felt that the volume was the most
important so it would be anywhere from
like three
to seven sessions a day
um
going from school to school from new
york to new jersey
and i think the volume was very
important to build the skills
um
where i just
didn't know how to move my body at
purple belt the way that i should so i
think that building the skills
is uh is super important i think that
early on volume is very important
now that i already have the skills built
i think that acquiring more knowledge is
the most important
so i find that if i do
so many sessions a day like if i do
three sessions a day
i feel sometimes by the third session
i'm just like so mentally like there's
just there's so much information that's
been through my head the first two
sessions that i feel like i'm not even
there mentally on the third session um
so i feel like doing less volume now but
having more mental clarity per session
is more important because i already have
the foundational skills acquired
so a lot of your training is almost like
just thinking
like learning a lot of it yeah so i'll
do like i mean our schedule has been
messed up since the pandemic because
henzo's got shut down and they were
using a french gym in puerto rico and
now we're using a french gym in our in
in austin but once we have our own
school we'll have a setup schedule where
i can pretty much just be there all day
long but right now i do like a lifting
session in the morning and then i'll
come in and help teach
at enzo so i'm there mentally i'm seeing
what's going on and i'm playing around
with ideas in my head
and then i'm there physically and very
sharp mentally for the competition class
during the 1pm session and then after
that i'll go home i'll rest and get
ready for the next day
what have you learned on seeing all
these different athletes is there a
a universal rule that applies or is it
um athletes specifically
first one thing that needs to be
addressed is that george and gordon play
very different sports with very
different athletic demands
gordon can be in matches that range from
anywhere from six
minutes to
literally hours long
as a result
the overall
pacing and intensity of matches is
massively different
most obviously there is no striking in
gordon's sport um striking by its very
nature is a much more explosive physical
action than grappliness grappling is
primarily an isometric
kind of sport based around isometric
tension and endurance
georgia sport is
does feature a significant amount of
isometric tension but
the majority of it is based around
explosion so the physical demands of the
two sports are radically different
in addition the time of application is
radically different george raised a very
interesting point his matches seem long
25 minutes for a championship match
but always understand that
it makes martial arts fight
at championship level
if it goes the distance is really
five five-minute matches each round
is a match in itself and that's exactly
how you're scored you're scored by who
wins the most matches over five matches
as a result the application of the
techniques especially the grappling
techniques has to be done at a certain
pace as george pointed out realistically
the maximum application time you're
going to get in most situations is
somewhere between
15 seconds and and three minutes
even for a specialized grappler like
damien meyer there's still a significant
part of each round which is spent in
setup time to actually get the match to
the ground
it's very likely that at some point your
opponent will stand up out of grappling
and you'll have to reinitiate the entire
process again so that even for
specialized grapplers you might be
spending only
three minutes out of a five-minute round
on the ground
and as a result you've got to get your
work done
in a very short time frame
gordon ryan
once it goes to the ground and it can go
to the ground because he chooses to sit
to the ground
uh who may spend the entire match in
ground positions
um
as a result the matches have completely
different pacing and completely
different physical demands and the
preparation that the two athletes go
through will reflect that
uh
if george st pierre in training for
mixed martial arts becomes fatigued to a
point where he's no longer physically
effective and able to defend himself the
consequences for that and mma training
can be very deep and deep
okay if you make a mistake in mixed
martial arts because you're fatigued and
tired and you take a full power
roundhouse kick to the head
that's some deep consequences a grappler
doesn't have to face that you can be
completely exhausted and grappling and
just sit in the bottom of the mountain
just practice just survival skills we
just don't get submitted from bottom out
and that can still be an effective
training session
complete and utter physical breakdown of
fatigue can be
can end an athlete's career in mixed
martial arts
the consequences of training through
fatigue and mma are
potentially very deep and very
disturbing
the consequences of training through
complete physical exhaustion and
grappling aren't really that severe
okay you just tap whenever there's a
problem just tap
um
and so they're very very different
sports in the way you you prepare for
them um
and a grappling
athlete like gordon ryan we can take
many more liberties with physical
exhaustion and the amount of hours a day
you spend in training than you could
with a mixed martial arts athlete like
actually be a benefit uh exhaustion as a
as a framework of learning so like from
a place of exhaustion
is there any benefit to that you want
you said being at the bottom of mouth
sort of understanding jiu-jitsu or
grappling somehow deeper because you're
physically absolutely absolutely because
then the only thing you have left in
your favor is your technique and then
you'll see how technical you are in
addition you'll get to explore realms
inside your mind that we don't spend a
lot of time in
and you'll learn a lot about yourself
and your ability to endure which will
have uh
potentially great benefits in similar
situations and matches yeah there's uh i
mean for me for a recreational person
getting
exhaustion allows you the great benefit
to experience what it feels like to
really get dominated
at an even greater frequency than you
otherwise would
and there's something there there's some
animalistic thing that's very unpleasant
and then afterwards it takes you to a
nice to a place of
like um humility and
and you get it forces you to rethink
life
in positive ways
there's something about dominance like i
mean if you get dominated a few times
you can uh rationalize it somehow you
say okay well i've screwed this up but
when you're exhausted and you have to do
like 30 minutes or 40 minutes or an hour
of just being domi over and over and
over being submitted
it uh i don't know it's a very good
process for
for other avenues of life i find it's i
can't explain why because i'm i'm i'm
driving home
crying afterwards listening to bruce
springsteen but afterwards
you this
afterwards somehow you can think clearly
you can see clear about what is the
right path through life in all walks of
life like relationships work but also
the grappling
actually the grappling is the hardest
one to see what you have to do
it clarifies other avenues the humility
it removes the [ __ ]
it's like we see
the world through some kind of fog and
it just removes it and now you can see
things clearly i don't know what that is
i think i think it's important like you
mentioned to push yourself like
sometimes
to see
how far you can go because sometimes you
you can go further than in what you
think
and it can boost your confidence you
know you can push yourself through a
certain limit
and maybe you thought your limit were
was before that point and you pushed to
it
but
like john just mentioned
it's a risky thing to do in
striking because if you're exhausted
you're gonna get brain damage
and grappling it's you know you tap if
something wrong but you can do it also
in strength conditioning i like to run
track i do it all the time and track and
fill
it it helps me to
to to know myself better i think it's
important so it's a good point uh
it's like it's like the scrimmage
wrestling rounds we do it's like you
know if you stop moving
that you're gonna get scored on and you
know in your mind like there's no
mechanical reason
why i am why i should give up a score
here but you're so exhausted that you're
like oh man this is terrible if i if i
stop moving i'm a [ __ ]
if i don't stop moving if i don't stop
moving i'm going to be twice as
exhausted when we actually do stand up
so it's a it's an interesting game you
have to play inside your mind it's your
pride very often that that
keep you
that keep you
sharp you know what i mean because you
just want to lay down and beat it
because you're completely exhausted you
know